Ringgold: When I grew up,
there were no cars
in the street.
Very few people had cars.
I was born in 1930 in Harlem
on 146th Street,
and now, my work
is all over the world.
The Guggenheim, the Tate--
everywhere.
[singing]
Interestingly enough,
I never thought of myself
becoming an artist.
I just thought of artist
as something that you do.
Everybody does it.
Look at that.
Aren't they beautiful?
The art of a people
comes from what they are seeing
around them,
and I saw so many
beautiful color combinations
and I interpreted
what I was looking and seeing.
Anyone can fly.
All you got to do is try.
The most important thing
to me in life
is inspiration.
I want to inspire others,
and I want to be inspired.
Isn't that something?
[drum music]